we have also discussed the peace process
in ukraine as you well know ms merkel
has done a lot to resolve the ukrainian
crisis
she has been at the foundation
of the normandy format and we have all
done our best to
to
restart and to
to have peace in ukraine
today we have discussed the
uh potential hostilities and ways to
avoid them in ukraine
starting
from august there has been over 3 000
cases of violation of ceasefire
and there has been bombing of
settlements and cities in donbass every
day
there has been a number of laws and
bylaws
in ukraine that violate the minsk
agreements and it seems to us that the
government of ukraine
has given up
uh trying to achieve peace
once again uh we call upon
ms merkel to
try to talk to the ukrainian government
and de korean officials and make them
carry out their obligations as per the
minsk accords